Opposers, I want
to talk about tests.
They're how we found out which
kids to wedgie in high school,
and which imaginary
school we fake go to.
But, the most
important test in America
is the NRA loyalty
questionnaire.
Where politicians
answer questions
about their commitment
to gun rights,
and then the NRA judges
them on a scale
between 'A' for 'all guns,
all day' down to
'F' for '(bleep) this guy.'
That's how they decide
whether to give you money
or grind you into the ground
with attack ads
until the only job
you'll be able to get
is Flint Michigan water taster.
So fun.
And...
The latest test is being
conducted down in Florida,
our most gun-shaped state.
The NRA is sending out these
questionnaires to lawmakers
asking where they stand
on the gun issues. -Questions
on the survey
asked lawmakers
whether they would consider
repealing many provisions
in the Marjorie Stoneman Douglas
High School Public Safety Act
including the ban
on bump stocks,
the three day waiting period,
and the new age restrictions
on purchasing a gun.
Yes, you had four months
of extremely meager
gun control laws
passed after
the parkland shooting
but school's out for summer
baby.
That means students need
to chill with the gun control
and teachers need to focus on
their third and fourth day jobs.
But, some Libs are going
to find any reason to get upset
Anna Eskamani, a Democrat
running for an Orlando house
seat shamed the NRA on Twitter
for sending the questionnaire
just two weeks
before the two year anniversary
of the post nightclub shooting.
OK.
It's a little close
to the anniversary of Pulse.
But to be fair, they wanted
to do it in May
until the Santa Fe shooting
happened and April wouldn't work
because that's Columbine season
and July is all tied up
with the anniversary
of the Aurora shooting.
It's just so hard
to schedule around mass
shooting anniversaries
for some reason.
Anyway back to how
we need more guns.
This questionnaire is perfect.
You're allowed to fill out
the test with a black pen,
a number two pencil,
or a 22 magnum.
And don't even think
about not answering
because the NRA won't just
mark them incomplete,
they'll mark them an attack
on freedom, you dirty communist.
There's a line
right at the top
that says "unanswered
questions will be graded
as a response against
Second Amendment rights."
But the questions
are totally easy like:
will you support
the right to bear arms,
look to repeal three day
waiting periods,
and push to finally let people
bring guns to church preschools?
You know. No brainer stuff.
But this is just the test
that got leaked to the press.
There's a whole other NRA test
with the tough questions.
Like this math question:
A train is traveling 100 miles
per hour going west.
Another train is
traveling 85 going east.
Should people be allowed
to have guns at the DMV?
And would you
support legislation
called The Bazooka Law?
No questions asked.
So listen up NRA politicians.
Work hard, study up, and relax
If you can shrug off
the teenage victims
of school shootings,
you're truly capable
of anything.